hey it's everyone i'm doing another one
of my fiverr gigs where i'm reviewing
somebody's website and today i'm looking
at charles's website and we are looking
at
creditcard.slavery.com so i'm gonna load
it up and give charles some of my
feedback on what to do so here's his
website this is the home page i guess at
first glance i kind of get what you do
so credit card debt slavery helping
those in debt to become debt free so
this is this is great and that explains
what you do i know why i'm coming to
this website i know what you can
potentially offer me here
i'd love to see a couple things on this
home page okay first of all i'd love to
see
an opinion that you stand for okay so
what's wrong with the market right now
and make me feel something make me feel
a connection to you if you're telling
your story or if you're giving me a
strong opinion you're telling me
what's broken
put some more content on this page
beyond just this one tagline you were
asking i think here somewhere about do
you feel i've optimized my blog for the
keyword phrase creditcard.slavery okay
it's in your title tag it's in your you
know url you put it here but you need
content you want to have at least 500
words of content on each page and
there's not a lot of content on this
page so you could do a double whammy of
adding content not just for search
engines but also for people who are
visiting your site to feel a connection
here to feel like yeah this guy
understands my story and i want to learn
more about him
you could definitely use a design lift
too so you might want to look at this
looks like it's a wordpress theme so
yeah we're person you can look at
a premium wordpress theme you can look
at some other free ones you can maybe
spend 50 bucks to get a better theme or
go to
you know get a nice logo made for
yourself you can look at websites like
99 designs it doesn't have to cost you a
lot of money and it will make it look a
little nicer right now it looks a little
bit homemade and i definitely want to
improve the layout and the design of the
site i'm looking at all these pictures
that are floating by here and some of
them are
like i can't click on them right it's
kind of confusing and some of them
aren't the greatest quality i saw one
back here that had had logos across the
top like this one here right you can
tell it's a stock photo
you know you want to improve this and
make it
it's meaningful to the the site but i'm
confused and that usually i can click on
this and this should lead to to blog
posts that tell me more about what
you're up to the credit doctor i i'm
assuming that's what you are are called
i don't know what i click let's click on
this and see what i get
if you're calling yourself a credit
doctor i don't know i'd love to see more
about you on here i'd love to see some
testimonials of people who have loved
your content but let's dig down a little
deeper and see what we can find so i'm
going to click on one of these
one of these links here they seem to go
to pdfs i'll click on recent posts about
me
what's on your mind and see what pops up
so the first one was a credit doctor
link so this here
looks like it goes to a sales letter
page so this is this is you know it's
looking like an affiliate page so you're
trying to promote this product maybe it
comes from clickbank or whatever it is
again you know if you want to sell this
product you got to tell me
why this is important
don't rely just on this this woman and
the sales letter page you want to drive
people to this page and you got to tell
me why
that product is great if you used it if
you had experience with it the biggest
problem with people are just promoting
affiliate products is they have no
personal connection to what they're
selling and so it's not credible
right if it's your own product it's a
different story but if you're
recommending somebody's product if
you're selling it you have to have a
personal attachment to it a personal
story and taking me on a journey to
explain where you were and why this
company helped solve your problem
so that goes to a landing page
which is that gives you a nice annoying
pop-up on the way out so this is one of
the reports here 13 credit myths 13
credit miss
so this looks nicely designed if you
have bad credit there's nothing you can
do repair doctor credit repair doctor
what was on here the credit doctor so
credit doctor credit repair doctor we're
not quite using the same terminology
uh this is great but it leads to another
website here so i guess again it's a
sales tool to try to get people to that
page i'd love to see you creating this
stuff so not not the company but you
create your own stuff with your picture
on it and you have your 13 this or
whatever it is i'd love to see you build
up yourself as an authority so people
come and they trust you and they they
want you to help them get out of
whatever problem they're facing with
their debt right now and if that works
if you can build up a following if you
can get people excited by what you're
offering then you can sell any kind of
product you can sell this one clickbank
product or a whole host of others that
you personally believe in because you
have a loyal audience and you've built
up a relationship with them uh recent
posts
so i guess there's nothing here yet uh
this looks like just a picture okay so i
mean so you got to add some content here
nothing has been put up yet but it's
fine
about me hello and welcome i'm charles
mcduffie all right i started this blog
because i can identify with those who
are in over their heads
i filed the chapter 7 bankruptcy because
i would run over thirty thousand dollars
in credit card debt wow i feel that
bankruptcy was the best way for me to
get my life back creditors to start
pounding me to death
so this is great this is this is what i
want to see more of and and
congratulations to you because a lot of
people who are just promoting affiliate
products they never even tell their
story at all what i'd love to see here
is
a higher quality picture here not in
terms of your your look but just the
pictures pixelated and hard to see
and fill this out more like take me on a
journey make me know what you felt and
what happened and and how you got out of
it right it says this blog is dedicated
to helping those who are in debt break
the chains
what happened to you what happened after
your bankruptcy and and let me know how
you broke free and and more of your
mission like this this is a powerful
page because if people believe in your
message on here if they get tied to you
personally then they'll read everything
that you put out and they'll say charles
knows what i'm feeling and i'm going to
trust in him to take me out of this and
that's what you want you want to build
yourself up as an authority that people
will listen to and and if you recommend
a product you want them to buy it right
this is your personal recommendation and
not just that one product but tons
ongoing
i love to see some kind of newsletter
here too right the only thing that they
can do
is buy your product or or contact you
i love to see some kind of way for them
to get content on an ongoing basis so
you're kind of dating them before you're
asking them to get married and take an
action with you
sign up for your newsletter get some
more information
and then you can follow up with them
with great content and then also product
sales afterwards but i love this page
you got to really blow this one up
and then what's on your mind so this is
great you can ask a question maybe you
do like a video response i don't see any
social media links anywhere here
but it's great that you have the option
for people to write into you
so i guess uh summarizing here
it's a great has great potential
again the biggest challenge with a lot
of these affiliate websites is there's
no personal story no personal connection
and you actually have a story here this
isn't just hey i'm trying to make money
off of people who are in debt you've
been there you understand it and i
didn't see any of that until i really
got to the about me page so i put that
front and center
have something on the homepage have your
face have a little clip about your store
where they can click more on to get to
the about page really make me feel
something make me feel that you really
understand me
explain how you felt and what led to it
and how you got out of it and and i want
to do the same right if i'm in debt i
want to do the same thing i want i want
your advice and expertise and if you can
make me connect to you then i'll sign up
for your newsletter and i'll buy your
product and i'll follow you and i'll i'm
trusting you so to build that trust you
have to tell more of your story and
build it up from there but it's a good
start um again tell more your story
maybe invest a little design and and
keep me posted with your progress
obviously it's a new site you haven't
done much on it yet but i'm excited to
see where this thing can go
for those who watching you like the
video give it a thumbs up below let me
know what you think i'd love to hear a
comment leave it below you have a
question put it in the comments i'll
make a video response thank you so much
and i'll see you soon